both dion warwick and dolly parton got
to see themselves impersonated on
snl this past weekend uh dion was played
by
eggo wodum and ellie pardon was played
by melissa viacenor
yeah we'll get to dion's reaction after
but dolly loved it
she tweeted i was flattered and i've
never looked and sounded so good
have a holy jolly christmas
it's the best time of the year
now i don't know if there'll be snow
but have a cup of cheer oh
i just love christmas you know what
other song i really like
jingle bells okay what a classic right
goes like this
[Music]
jingle bells jingle bells jingle bells
all the way i'm thinking of you please
don't take jolene
welcome to the dion warwick talk show
maybe you know me from my music
or maybe you have heard that i just
discovered twitter
and these are actual tweets i tweeted
out
hi chance the rapper if you are very
obviously a rapper why did you put it in
your stage name
i cannot stop thinking about this let's
bring out our next guest
miss william eyelash
[Applause]
yeah my name is actually billy eilish
i'm a singer
i'm the bedtime make your mama mad type
i'm a bad guy that's wonderful
so kesha no
okay yeah so dionne has become a twitter
sensation over the past couple weeks and
she didn't disappoint
in her reaction to snl so she tweeted i
just logged on to tell eggo snl
and the other young lady that they did a
wonderful job
i hope you all have a great sunday i'll
come back if i get bored
heart bye and then she said i took the
time to check out william eyelash
very spooky great vocals billy eilish
she's singing like it is halloween
i thought her name was william eyelash
from the snl performance
i do know her name is billy now
i wish they could have kept the dionne
warwick
um being funny on twitter going longer
but she blew it
right days into it right she was when
she did the interview with andy cohen
and you know and you could have you
could have strung this along for years
really and she could have built this
entirely new
persona but to me now dionne warwick on
twitter
the the illusion is gone right you know
you know it's not dionne warwick
and and and it's sort of heartbreaking
because i think that that's exactly what
we
you know what we sort of needed is to
see somebody like you know dion warwick
trending
in 2020. i thought it was extremely
endearing but uh she's having fun with
it yeah nelson says dolly could never
give a bad critique
i don't think dolly would ever say a bad
word about anybody
yeah yeah he says the dolly impression
was great it's funny too like i mean
this past week of snl like both of us
and eggo got some great uh
sketches because this is the first week
i think in quite a while
that we haven't had jim carrey we
haven't admired rudolph we haven't out
baldwin like it was actually about
the cast other than of course the host
timothy shalom so it's actually nice to
see these people get these opportunities
to do
somewhat random impersonations like you
didn't think you'd see dolly parton on
snl in 2020 but
it was really really fun to see it was
unique to see
yeah and snl is geez man
snl used to be the thing you did at
saturday nights at
at 11 at 11 30 and snl now
is you know you sort of go through and
catch the highlights of whatever's the
top trending the next day
you know twitter does the hard work for
you where they tell you what the best
bits
of snl of snl were and and they and they
and they really
are but uh but but dolly parton you are
right dolly party's not going to say a
bad thing about anybody
and dolly parton's reactions to
everything dolly parton
are always the best reaction yeah
they're both fantastic yeah it was super
fun
[Music]
i love this i can listen to her do this
all day